قانون قناه السويس سيادتك هو 16 ماده انت
عملت حضرتك من هذا القانون من الماده 15
تسع عماوات الصندوق هو صندوق تفريخ
موازنه مصر من اموالها هو صندوق حضرتك
يستدعي الاجنبي من خلال طرح الاوراق
الماليه في البرصه هو سيادتك قانون خطير
وقطر داهم نرفضه تماما القانون الذي يجعل
صندوق يقوم باستئجار باستئجار حضرتك
وبيع الاصول بهذا امر خطير قانون لقناه
السويس يا اللي مات فيه
120,000 مصري في انشاء قناه السويس
النهارده
من مضمونه سياده الرئيس انا باحول المال
العام الى مال خاص يا سياده الرئيس هذا
القانون خطر داهم على مصر ويذكرني تماما
بقانون او محاوله استئجار وبيع جزء من
الاهرامات في السبعينات انها قناه السويس
يا سياده الرئيس
وليست شركه من الشركات التي تم بيعها من
الدم الشعب المصري بارخص الاسبان نرفض هذا
القانون يا سياده الرئيس
[موسيقى]